We are finally down to the last hours, fewer
than 24 hours left in Donald Trump's reign
of terror, depending on when you listen to
this and when you watch today's show, and
somehow as we really get ourselves ready for
a new administration, a new president, a new
start, hopefully turning into experiencing
an inflection point when it comes to coronavirus
and starting to go in a better direction,
we still are seeing these last gasps of desperation
from Donald Trump to see if maybe somehow
he could do something to open the window even
slightly to remaining in power and now abandoned
by so many.
Having conceded, and I use that term very
narrowly conceded that there will be a transition,
that there will be a new administration.
Donald Trump over the weekend had my pillow
CEO Mike Lyndell at the White House, who was
spotted holding notes, were zoomed in, photos
showed martial law and other of these harebrained
ideas.
And we're going to look at the details.
And, of course, as Rolling Stone and others
have been reporting, we know Trump is out
of options.
We know that we are mere hours from Donald
Trump leaving the office of the presidency
in shame, having lost the House for Republicans
in twenty eighteen, having lost the Senate
for Republicans in 2020, and having made himself
a one term president and in so doing led to
one of the biggest global failures on coronavirus,
the court challenges didn't work.
Pressuring Republican politicians to try to
do weird things on January six didn't work.
Focusing on the December 14th electoral vote
counts.
None of it worked.
But Trump had my pillow guy Mike Lyndell at
the White House seen entering on Friday, whose
notes discussed martial law and Mike Lyndell.
Although I'm not going to play any of these
agit trash interviews that he's been doing,
including from his private jet, insisting
that there are still ways there is still a
path forward, somehow it appears as though
as recently as 48 hours ago, Donald Trump
was still exploring options and still listening
to people who had these ideas about martial
law.
Mike Lyndell notes also said Insurrection
Act now as a result of the assault, something
something martial law if necessary.
So that is Michael Mondelēz idea for Donald
Trump.
Now, importantly, why is a pillow manufacturer
who believes Trump is a gift from God advising
a president of the United States?
Well, the answer is in the question because
he believes Trump is a gift from God.
And these are exactly the types of people
that Donald Trump puts around him.
He doesn't put an infectious disease expert
around him to manage a pandemic.
He puts a neuro radiologist around him to
manage a pandemic who happens to have a view
favorable to that of Donald Trump.
And really, I mean, listen, I don't know about
every country, but it seems that it is unique
to the United States that a guy who sells
pillows on late night right wing media would
become a close adviser to a president, particularly
in that president's final, desperate, shameful
days in office during a global of a global
crisis, the likes of which we haven't seen
for 100 years, the coronaviruses pandemic.
So I received, you know, a ton of comments
about this story, about how terrible the my
pillow pillows are.
Now, I can't speak to that.
I've never bought one of them.
I never would.
But the important part is not about the pillows.
It's why is the pillow guy meeting with the
president of the United States to offer advice
and in particular with a document that says
martial law written on it, but it all tracks.
If you call Scott Atlus to help you run infectious
disease, why not call a pillow guy?
Right.
If you want or believe Jared Kushner is going
to solve the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
in four years, then it tracks that you would
call a pillow guy to advise you as to how
to try to stay in power despite having lost
an election.
So it's all embarrassing.
It's all pathetic.
There are already discussions of, you know,
is this beyond what should be pardoned by
Joe Biden in the style of Gerald Ford pardoning
Richard Nixon?
I'm going to address that over the next day.
I'll preview my position.
The answer is absolutely not.
There is no way, under no circumstances should
Joe Biden even consider a preemptive pardon
of Donald Trump.
Now, there's not a sign yet that Joe Biden
plans.
To do that, but there are more and more people,
some on the right, some on the left, some
nonpartisan who are saying for the unity of
the country, Joe Biden should look at pardoning
Donald Trump because it'll put an end to this
stuff.
Now, this stuff ends in 24 hours anyway.
And I believe it would be a grave mistake
to pardon Donald Trump.
But I will get to that.
I don't want to get ahead of myself before
we get to Joe Biden being in a position to
pardon anybody, we have to get through tomorrow's
inauguration.
And I want to talk about the horrible things
going
on there.